the streets of paris are once again
eerily quiet fear of a third wave
with cases on the rise across europe is
forcing new lockdowns to spread across
the continent
with the restrictions comes resentment
it's exhausting
tiring it's long i hope it's going to
end quite quickly
it's quite sad to see the city
completely dead especially on the
champs-elysees
we understand the health situation but
on the other hand
after one year and taking a step back we
tell ourselves that the political
leaders could have taken better measures
questions too about the effectiveness of
the lockdown
as police check drivers amid claims
people are leaving the capital to head
to parts of the country
where lockdown isn't in force a rise in
cases in poland
means drivers crossing the border into
germany now have to prove they've had a
negative covert test
a lockdown in poland started this
weekend
meaning schools now have to close again
to some children and
all leisure activities and non-essential
shops
have had to close this is problematic
for us
above all because these decisions are
made overnight and we feel that they are
not consulted with us
of course we are observing the situation
in the country ourselves
so we know that it is serious and it is
indeed necessary to introduce changes
that will help stop the pandemic
across europe there's frustration with
the slow roll
out of vaccines even though use of the
astrazeneca vaccine has now resumed
the german health minister has warned
there simply aren't enough vaccine doses
in europe to stop
a third wave with cases rising
exponentially in the country
scientists say urgent action is needed
we need to go back to the lockdown
uh measures that were put in place
before march and we need to do that very
soon
from the beginning of march or march 9th
around
you see a doubling period of about two
weeks so that would imply that by easter
we have case counts that are comparable
or even
higher than what we observed during
christmas
many germans have been getting away
while they still can
these tourists were arriving in majorca
but with more restrictions seemingly
inevitable
travel to europe from the uk from may is
looking increasingly
in doubt becky johnson sky news